it's not an argument about about
defending people like Andrew Tate but
like but I think I think what's happened
is that is that you've had other people
people like uh Jordan Peterson people
like Joe Rogan who do exude a form of a
form of masculinity and put forward a
kind of vision of masculinity and those
people are treated as kind of extremists
too I think you can disagree with people
like like Jordan Peterson I certainly
don't think he's an extremist but part
of the problem is when you treat those
kinds of people in that way you give
rise to a to a kind of to an even kind
of further more extreme kind of thing
about it yeah exactly exactly and I
think that's part of the problem you
know I mean it's one of those things
that's that's kind of that's often
decried in the media the fact that there
aren't you know very many male role
models anymore but when they do pop up I
mean they are they are kind of
ruthlessly attacked and and so the boys
you know go looking for something even
more kind of extreme and mental